that's because of two experiences I had
one was that I had five four boys I had
four boys my wife and I had four boys in
36 months one of them was having trouble
breathing one night he fell back asleep
at about two in the morning so I didn't
take him to the emergency room right
away but I was wondering if I should so
I got online to see what I could learn
about baby's not breathing well you know
they don't give licenses to the parents
so I didn't actually have to go through
any training to be a parent and I got
online I ended up on WebMD and I said
you've got to be kidding me this is what
people experience around medicine all
these Botox ads and you know a magazine
article that goes for six pages and at
the end just says go see your physician
I was like wow there's not a lot of
value here so that was the first
experience I had the second experience I
had was when one of my boys got cut over
the eye and we went to the emergency
room because it was blood everywhere and
I don't know you just go to the
emergency room we got a bill for seventy
three hundred dollars and they didn't do
anything but put a bandaid on it and and
he's fine but you know there was three
or four people conference and decide
what to do about it but they put a
bandaid on his 7300 dollars you know i
paid down almost seven hundred dollars
out of pocket for that and and and i'd
never heard of an urgent care clinic I
you know I'm pretty educated but I had
never heard so our lack of knowledge
around how to actually interface with
the medical care system is profound so
those two experiences led me to want to
start something that used the principles
that I've learned over the last 15 years
about how the internet works about
distributed information management to
actually improve the situation so I went
to Mitch Kapoor who had founded Lhota
stand he and I were on the board a
second life which is another one of
these emergent systems and he I said
shouldn't we do something about this
shouldn't we you know and he's on the
wikimedia foundation board and you know
very involved with open source software
and he said yeah I've been thinking
about this for several years and I just
haven't had a chance to do it so why
don't you go do it so I went and went
back and started talking to two people
in the field I'd started my last company
with some Harbor professors and so I
went back to Harvard and I ended up
talking to the medical people the guys
running the harvard medical school and
they said this is a great idea this is
going to happen we don't know what it
looks like but you're probably the guy
to figure it out
let's let's do this so that's how it all
got going and as I've gotten more into
it I've really understood the sort of
difficulties of medical service design
if you will the design of the experience
of getting your health care so you can
call a doctor and you have to go through
six different you know buttons to try to
navigate to where you're supposed to be
that's kind of dangerous frankly the way
it's working today or you have to go to
the doctor's office and wait and by the
afternoon you know she's two hours
behind and you have to kind of wait and
then everyone in the office is sick and
so you're catching things from them you
know over a hundred thousand people a
year die from mistakes in hospitals and
whatnot in the United States and many
more hundreds of thousands get infected
with you know bugs and viruses that
exists only in hospitals they're very
virulent forms of things my father
almost died two years ago because of
this he went in for a knee operation and
got an infection that with a particular
type of virus that only exists in
hospitals now and and it almost killed
it it literally almost killed him they
had to open up his it is his neck to say
I mean it was crazy so the healthcare
system as it exists today has a lot of
challenges and the people who are
working on it are incredibly dedicated
they're incredibly talented they are
working so many hours and so hard and
they're incredibly well trained and and
it's still not getting better all that
much faster and so the application of
what is I think our generations greatest
greatest tool which is the internet and
coming now smartphones sort of mobile
equipment like a smartphone today is
more powerful than the typical computer
of 2001 facebook today is bigger than
the whole internet in 2002 like things
are really changing in terms of
information technology this is an
enormous hammer that we can use an
enormous tool we can use to help improve
things for what is a life-or-death issue
for people around medicine so I think we
can go from a place where service is
poor not because people don't want
service to be good because they're
trying their best but the methodologies
and the tools that we use today
are just inferior to what almost every
other industry is using and so I think
we can move us from there from one place
to the next over the next four or five
years and really make a difference